so we had another weekend as often
happens every week and what that means
in practice is that our president has
again unleashed another furious tweet
storm riddled with spelling and grammar
errors and random capitalization of
words and the topic this time with
Supreme Court justice Brett Kavanaugh
there are new sexual assault allegations
against Brett Kavanaugh despite having
been told during the confirmation
hearings of wrecked Aven odd that the
FBI looked into all of the allegations
into Brett Kavanaugh not surprising not
shocking more allegations of surfaced
including ones that the FBI did not look
into during his confirmation hearings
and the the particulars of the latest
allegation are that Kavanaugh exposed
his most intimate of areas use your
imagination to a female Yale classmate
and that others subsequently pushed the
hands of the classmate into Cavanaugh's
most intimate of areas nothing shocking
about this nothing surprising this seems
to just be who Brett Kavanaugh is it
became very very clear of course no
particular reason now to be concocting
this some of the normal twitter
hangers-on suggesting that it's because
we are now 14 months from an Italian
that now some bogus allegation against
an already confirmed Supreme Court
justice who is almost impossible to
remove makes sense for political reasons
which I mean if you're gonna concoct
something concoct something that
actually has a shot at doing some damage
to the person involved Donald Trump
flying off the handle as a result
immediately suggesting that Cavanaugh
sufer listen to this one he should sue
for liable now why am i pronouncing it
liable because that's how Trump spelled
it Li a ble I guess meaning of course L
IBE L libel a published false statement
damaging to a person's reputation Trump
concocting a bizarre conspiratorial
series of tweets first tweeting Brett
Kavanaugh should start suing people for
liable or the Justice Department should
come to his rescue which by the way the
Justice Department coming to his rescue
is an extremely authoritarian suggestion
Trump going on the lies being told about
him are unbelievable false accusations
without
criminais does it stop they are trying
to influence his opinions can't let that
happen
eventually Trump deleted it and reposted
it with the corrected spelling of a
libel and then kept going with more
quote can't let Brett Kavanaugh give
radical left Democrat liberal Plus
opinions each one of those words
capitalized why we don't know based on
threats of capital I impeaching him over
made-up stories sound familiar
false allegations and lies this is the
game they play fake and corrupt News is
working overtime
hashtag protect Cavanaugh I these are
the true these are the rantings of the
equivalent of someone again who's
yelling at you while they urinate on the
subway tracks on Canal Street of while
you wait for the 6:00 train I'll do one
more tweet not the entire list of tweets
because it's it's a quite frankly just
too much to keep up with Trump tweeting
I am fighting the fake corrupt news the
deep state the Democrats and the few
remaining Republicans in name only
rhinos who are on mouth-to-mouth
resuscitation with the help of some
truly great Republicans and others we
are winning big one hundred and fiftieth
federal judge this week now the last
thing Trump mentions there 150 federal
judges Trump's right about this I've
talked about this before
Supreme Court selections get a lot of
attention federal judgeships much less
so and Donald Trump is actually winning
really big with those federal judgeship
selections it gets very little attention
it has a huge impact and it has a huge
impact for a very long time in most
cases never make it to the Supreme Court
a lot of the important precedent in this
country is ultimately decided by federal
judges many of which have now been
appointed by Donald Trump I think we
found that about 25% of current federal
and Superior Court I forget the
categorizations have been selected by
Trump in just two years and this has a
massive massive impact now as far as the
subject matter the idea of libel suits
against accusers of Kavanaugh consider
for a second that there have been what
15 16 1920 women who have accused Donald
Trump of anything
ranging from verbal sexual harassment
all the way up to an including rape
Donald Trump has not filed a single
libel lawsuit I wonder why that is
if anybody who is falsely accused of
sexual assault deserves to be have to
have a libel lawsuit filed against them
and it would be something in which one
could prevail
why hasn't Donald Trump filed a single
libel lawsuit against all of his
accusers and of course there will not be
any libel lawsuits by Brett Kavanaugh
against these accusers either and I
think we all know why that is going back
once again to the idea from Donald
Trump's tweets that he's fighting the
fake corrupt media this is the last
thing I want to touch on Trump's not
fighting the fake corrupt media the fake
corrupt news media as Trump calls it or
I just call it corporate media they are
in on the game and what I mean by that
is that you have some in corporate media
that just will defend Trump endlessly or
almost endlessly like Fox News others
take a more critical editorial
perspective MSNBC others play the
enlightened watchdogs with bipartisan
panels like CNN but they're all
participating in the game they create
and suck out all the ratings that they
can from the distraction stories and
narratives that Donald Trump creates and
then when the time is up they just move
on to the next thing never really
closing the book on the impact of each
of these narratives and Trump is simply
wrong because they are actually working
with him the fight is the public spin on
it but the reality is that corporate
media have been in with Trump including
the billions and free publicity that
they gave him from the time he started
his campaign that is backwards Trump has
that backwards and again Trump is
completely erratic and unhinged every
single weekend on Twitter